oh oh
rail slide 900 points right there bro
tony hawk is jealous oh bro god damn
matt
pick her ass up that's a hard one
looking good though doctor who came so
far
doctor who came so far
he's like give me that oh dark sister
he's such a pun
he's ready to go you're not supposed to
do this oh well he has a mace i guess
well once you're off the horse you gotta
you gotta go fisticus
a mace versus a sword who'da thought
who'd have thought who would've thought
they're both look at them swing i know
they're they're coming for blood and
they weren't both even holding their
shield
up
down down now i have the high ground no
i haven't who has the high ground now
matt smith
oh damn
oh that's good oh my he threw the shield
at him look at that hair matching mine
look at her
pedro pascal did the same thing baby oh
secret knife gotta have a secret knife
and so you get stepped on yield
he doesn't want to yield
look at that face
he's so pissed he's so pissed off
[Applause]
get out of here that's like the best get
geez louise welcome back to new rock
stars house of the dragon has taken us
back in time to westeros to the height
of the targaryen rule succession is
still the most important thing in the
realm and it's clear that the maesters
have no idea what they're up to when it
comes to health care literally they said
let me just put my fingers in the mud
and then into your wife into your queen
you guys i wish i could have tweeted out
before
three horrific trigger warnings oh my
gosh warn some people when you're
watching well what was i supposed to i
don't know the time stamp so be like
okay once they get to the golden uh the
the uh the golden uh the golden clothes
yeah the golden clothes
once they're howling to go out and kick
some ass yeah anytime you see an angry
face maybe just turn away from the
camera oh my god how is anyone alive in
westeros and literally this has more
violence in the first episode than the
first like five in game of thrones oh my
gosh we saw
sean bean get beheaded we didn't see
anyone get castrated
jesus they're coming hard you guys this
is big question presents talking dragons
our weekly fantasy after show
oh look at that look at that baby big
question presents i'm jessica clemons
and with me today is brandon barrack oh
hello jessica so good to be here today
so happy to talk some game of thrones uh
and while this series is based on the
george rr martin novel fire and blood uh
we're only gonna use that as a reference
for the past history we're not gonna
spoil any upcoming stuff on the show so
you're safe to watch this show if you
haven't read the book uh we're gonna go
through it as the show goes through it
and if you tuned in today you're look
and you're looking for your standard bq
uh don't worry it'll be back soon we'll
be back to our regular big questions
soon we just had so much fantasy shows
coming down the pipeline and the
streaming tubes we had to make some room
on the channel for a little kings and
rings if you know what i mean kings and
rings so we're gonna dive into episode
one of house of the dragon the heirs of
the dragon okay oh my god so it's almost
200 years before the events of what we
would know uh to be as game of thrones
uh king jaharis has done a great job of
overseeing westeros during a time of
peace but he has no sons left alive uh
and it's time for him to name a
successor in an effort to keep the peace
he calls a great council to let the
lords decide
the lords decide who should be king the
lords they pick uh viserys targaryen
which rightfully pisses off princess
rhaenys uh targaryen who believes it to
be her right and she goes on to be known
as the queen that never was and also
that that's the shitty part you know it
comes with that horrible nickname of
like yeah you're the queen that never
was and it's like
i could have been if i wasn't a girl you
didn't have to give me that name that's
fine
uh so we have a new king we jump ahead
to nine years in viserys the first rule
and now king viserys himself needs his
own heir his wife emma aaron emma aaron
is pregnant and trying her best to bring
her husband a son but she's had some
unsuccessful pregnancies in the past and
she knows like this is pretty much her
last chance she's not going through this
baby stuff again uh and she won't
i love that she honestly though in their
relationship very lovely yeah he was
like yeah i'm fine with that like unlike
the successor to the throne as viserys
oldest child but the targaryens aren't
ready to have that conversation if you
know what i mean there's never been a
queen in westeros
this is a patriarchy we can't have that
uh she's she's a fearless dragon rider
who flies around on the golden dragon
c-rex a beautiful looking dragon
uh and her good friend and confidant is
alyssa allison hightower who is also the
daughter of the hand of the king auto
hightower a lot of names in this episode
a lot of names a lot of a lot of names a
lot of faces a lot of names a lot of
faces if you've read game of thrones you
know it's mostly just names the thing is
in the first game of thrones how was it
easier to trap it was it because their
houses there were not as many houses as
right now what we're seeing well i think
because we're focusing on one house yeah
and all the people in it it's a little
insular right in the first episode
you're like in this city there's this
people yeah there's this area there's
that people but now we're just getting
kings okay all right so king viserys
also has a brother named damon targaryen
uh and he clearly has a lust for the
throne uh and the other members of the
king's council are clearly threatened by
his moves he's the head of the city
watch and he's taken a tough line on
what he sees as crime within king's
landing he introduces the gold cloaks to
the city watch and goes and has a grand
old night out in the murderer
murderer
he's doling out the justice baby uh he's
married to lady ria royce of the veil we
don't see her in this episode and he's
clearly not that into her uh he he
wields dark sister which is an ancestral
targaryen blade of valerian steel that
was used to conquer westeros back in the
day with aegon targaryen there's the
beautiful dark sister right there uh and
it's also clear that our boy damon is a
little sweet on his niece uh rainier
yeah he wants they have a close
relationship he wants uh well and that's
very targaryen thing to do they like to
merit keep it within the family uh which
is problematic
hey and now there's it's time for a
tournament to celebrate the coming of
the king's air uh king viserys is
betting on this baby coming in time for
the festivities and then it will be a
boy it's going to be a boy he promises
he's like it came to me in a dream i
would have been like as his wife i've
been like will you shut up i am so
pregnant i love her pointing out like
baby i better not be born with an iron
crown on
uh no thank you no thank you uh prince
damien decides to take part in this
tournament and show off he has a very
fetching suit of armor which we saw it's
gorgeous i mean you will see this at
your next renaissance fair uh at your
next comic con you're gonna see this
outfit it was beautiful um during the
tournament our good old queen that never
was uh reinis took valero on now she's
having an interesting conversation with
her husband lord corliss valeron and
it's clear that they both think that
westeros and the targaryen dynasty are
in the wrong hands as the tournament
winds down damon battles it out with a
mysterious stranger of dorne lineage sir
kristin uh and as damon celebrates his
assumed upper hand he winds up being
blinded by his hubris and loses the
tournament and perhaps even any chance
of gaining the throne for at the same
time as this tournament as promised by
king viserys uh
the baby is being born and it's not
going well and king viserys has to make
a tough decision he chooses to sacrifice
his wife in attempt to save his son uh
emma dies during the fourth c-section
and it soon revealed that the sun did
not survive either so he has no male
heir as sadness falls over king's
landing the king's council talks uh or
the king's council starts sharing their
concerns about the succession because
there's no one there now uh and there's
a lot of concern about damon coming in
to take the throne because there's
history uh in the targaryen lineage of
brothers coming in to take over the
throne
uh and the topic about ronira being
named a successor is brought up at the
time king viserys is in no mood to hear
any talk of succession having just lost
his wife and his son but otto hightower
has another plan up his sleeve as the
king's hand he sends a mysterious raven
to old town and then his sends his own
daughter a license to the king's
chambers he says put on one of your
mother's out put on one of mom's outfits
you really nail in the coffin you're
like oh maybe it is just to read a book
and then he's like why don't you go make
yourself pretty cue the dolly parton
here's your one chance fancy don't let
me down oh no oh baby oh no
um during an orgy damon makes a speech
where he goes on to call his recently
deceased nephew the quote heir for a day
tough tough stuff from my guy uh word of
this uh moniker makes it up the way to
the food chain and it pisses off his
brother viserys who has a few words for
his brother while sitting on the iron
throne uh striking an imposing throw uh
pose with black fire king vasara sends
his brother damon back to his wife at
runestone get out of here he says
he uh uh damon does leave but decides to
take his mistress with him as well as
the mighty dragon carraxis this is a big
that's an evil looking dragon this is a
grown-up dragon that is the evilest
looking dragon i've ever seen in my life
this was a hand-me-down dragon to damon
it belonged to someone else and he took
over uh
but doling out judgments as the king is
hard work as viserys seems to keep
getting injured by the very throne he
sits on he gets a little sliced on the
fingers got a little sore on his back
that's not healing better cauterize that
my guy uh
and it's during this time that he
finally realizes that maybe his daughter
should be queen after all what a good
girl dad finally coming around to the
realization that girls get it done uh he
warns his daughter that the dragons
brought valeria its doom and that the
targaryen should have never trifled with
them as they will be their downfall as
well some pretty uh
important foreshadowing right there he
names rhaenyra as his heir and the lords
the lords of the land pledged their
loyalty to princess rhaenyra the last
two lords we see uh doing this are
actually a baratheon and a stark
we don't have that in uh they don't like
i don't think they like the targans and
they certainly don't like a ladybug yeah
baratheon especially baratheon was like
they're not here get ready get ready for
the [ __ ] i'm gonna do but before it's
over viserys has one more warning for
renera the prophecy of the end of the
world of men the dream of aegon known as
the song of ice and fire ever heard of
it uh he's definitely right about this
happening but as we know it's more of a
tomorrow problem than a today problem
but it is interesting to see him so
concerned about it and so the house of
the dragon begins
you guys you guys before we get into the
meat meet me meat of it all we're gonna
start with be sure to head over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
our newest latest obsession shirt ash
and ruin inspired by the bloody civil
war to come from house of the dragon
this limited edition shirt wasn't uh
this limited edition shirt won't last
long so be sure to grab one when you can
and when you purchase this latest
latest obsession shirt you unlock the
opportunity to get a custom shout out
that will appear right here on talking
dragon that's right talking dragons i
know you guys want to say stuff and i'm
going to say it out loud
we'll talk your dragon speech yeah i'll
say your speech out loud you guys
whatever you want to say if you want to
pledge allegiance to uh damon i'll do it
uh i i mean you were gonna do that yeah
i was gonna do that regardless i put on
this wig for a reason yeah damon is like
your pro prototypical crush it's a
villain a tough guy
muscly
okay uh support the channel and check
out all of our awesome merch options
over at newrockstarsmerch.com
okay
well now that the chessboard has been
set for the season of the house of the
dragon we have to start wondering how
all of this uh how all of these
well-made plans will run amok it all
leads to leads us to our big question of
the reek remember it's big question
presents who is the biggest threat to
rhaenyra's rise to power oh okay okay uh
this is a good one this is a good one
because you know that's what this show
is gonna be about right it's all about
people even the uh at the end they have
like the like what's next and they're
straight up like
everyone wants that throne everyone
everybody wants to know that from game
of thrones in the past like that's the
importance of power you want to be there
no sense
i would immediately be like someone take
it from me yeah and this is a this is a
time when only targaryens have ruled
westeros aegon the conqueror he he
united the lands the seven kingdoms
except for doran they don't play along
uh but
it's only been targaryens with that
power and only males right and now
you're sick now we have the king saying
like okay the next one's going to be a
lady and everyone's like okay
maybe but we'll see about that because
vaners is still vasaris is still king
right now he's still the king
you don't think i do think rainey's
valerian is gonna be like especially
it's coming from within the house yeah
easy easy easy to like try a killing
yeah so you have like the queen that
never was right she's conspiring with
her husband she's like things aren't
going well we need to clean this up
these people are soft we gotta we gotta
get hard on them right okay we also have
uh you know damon targaryen you can send
him back to runestone he's just gonna
come back yeah
he's got a dragon he's got dark sister
he's ready to be the king he thinks his
brother's a pushover you know he's he's
a tough guy he wants to be the king he's
he's tired of being second fiddle we
also have otto hightower uh using his
daughter to kind of like slip in there
and find a place of power right because
if allison winds up you know getting
with the king and then she has a male
heir i i wouldn't be surprised if the
king is suddenly like hey rainier i know
we talked about i'm gonna need that
dagger back real quick if you girl get
that back real quick i know we had a
thing baby yeah thank you i still love
you you got this new stepmom i know she
was your friend but like you guys you
know you like why we already like
because you don't want people that own
dragons why would you mess with people
that own dragons it makes no sense uh
you guys always die we know this from
the book
right but they don't know that right the
dragons have brought them all this power
though i do love seeing like viserys
king viserys he takes this uh prophecy
of the song of ice and fire very
seriously it's a big deal to him he's
like this is important this is gonna
happen you need to be like ready for
this and that's interesting to see that
this was so important because this is
something that we know from game of
thrones was not as important anymore to
the king whoever was in this the
baratheons didn't care about it right no
i don't know if they were ever told
about it it seems like it was a
targaryen secret no 100 if they go and
you know when they kill the mad king and
just kind of take over i'm sure as he
was dying he wasn't like oh by the way
there's a problem
the prophet keep the wall up there's a
prophecy oh my god it it's so
interesting that he is actually i was i
was confused with it because i was like
it didn't seem like that big of a deal
but maybe it is just like the end of the
world of fun
no one was actually talking about it but
him and he's like
actively not a good king yeah so it's
like
well i meant like like if he's aware of
it happening you think he'd be a better
king right about the whole situation
he's putting a lot on his daughter to
actually go do everything i think that's
why everyone on his council is like yo
dude you're dying like we need to figure
this stuff out and he's like no i'm fine
and i'm like you're really playing this
very light when you are dying and when
you die no one's going to know about
this well and this has been a very
peaceful time and
yeah
yeah everyone's having uh viserys's
father king jaharis you know he
he's known as the conciliator he he kept
a lot of peace because before him there
was this guy known as maegor who was
like he was bloodthirsty he he ruled
with an iron fist he killed everybody
like for instance he saw the overseeing
of the building of the red keep
it got finished under his watch and he
had all these secrets built in it he got
all the builders together and he was
like great job boys oh yes yeah here's
some here's some ladies to entertain you
yeah and then the next day he killed off
yeah
then every time he needed something
built in the city they were like we need
new builders and they're like we don't
want a building you're gonna kill all of
us all right so he was waiting for them
westeros is like you know uh uh reyna
says this it's it's soft yeah you know
they've known mostly peace and king
viserys he's like a peace time king too
he's not trying to be hard yeah but
damon knows he's like you got to be hard
with these people you got to go in there
you got to cut off some dicks you got to
cut off some hands you got to collect
them all you got to travel with all the
pieces of them all you got to put them
in a cart you got to take them with you
wherever you go
uh that's what you got to do
but i i really think i think damon is
our biggest threat to me damon said well
he's going to come back
you guys he's going to come back with a
bunch of people like he's going to go
there and he's going to be like well it
looks like i got to start my own [ __ ]
bring them back and he still has a
dragon he still has that dragon so he is
going to stir up a ruckus but i just
think it's easier coming from within the
house and that's why i think the
valerian would make more sense to like
you think rain is like the big threat
yeah but maybe i'm maybe i'm playing it
too sneaky because i understand damon is
coming through and blowing blowing the
house down but like i'm like but that's
actually like remembering game of
thrones where she killed him with the
poison the mom killed him with the
poison it was that easy she was like
yeah i'm gonna let that man that crazy
man marry my daughter well even maegor
right maegor this like awful evil king
that no one could stop he was
mysteriously killed they found him he
was actually impaled on the iron throne
yes and people were like oh he was drunk
and he fell and he because we see how
the iron throne is dangerous right also
at this time there's all these like
swords
it's very book accurate because in the
book they all just like are everywhere
they're everywhere they're literally
everywhere you trip you fall on yeah
yeah and then
the show it's just the throne it's just
the truth well it's clear at some point
someone was like we gotta get these more
dangerous swords out of here we gotta we
gotta sand it a little bit make it a
little softer to sit on yeah maybe it
makes our king doesn't keep getting cut
and diseased by it right it's very
dangerous well and some might say like
that's the king that's the throne saying
like you're not fit to sit here you
think you're you're two i mean yeah yeah
but in reality it's just like this is a
dirty ass chair and you are getting
infected by it
uh but these kind of trials and
tribulations it's it's poetry right yeah
poetry and game of thrones we see a lot
of repeating because this has happened
in the past where like a a more
competent ruling more bloodthirsty
brother was sent away yeah and then
waits for the right moment and comes
back and takes what's his and then you
have people saying like no no i was
supposed to be the heir and then you
have uh you know a
tougher
guy like damon taking over and being
like okay you want to be the air come
and take it real talk and then like how
are you going to come and take it from
him if he's got the if he's got the city
watch under his hand he's got a big old
dragon he's got a big old sword the
valerian might be married
yeah i think that's something that could
definitely happen it seems like they're
hinting that damon and rhaenyra might
get married at some point
and if she wants to keep her position
and keep her power she might have to do
that but she doesn't seem to see
damon as like uh an evil guy well it's
because she's still people she's young
she's young right now we're seeing young
her and then we're gonna see older her
later but like she still is like my dad
hates me and her dad doesn't listen so
that's why she goes to her uncle yes and
i'm like girl he's bad
he cuts he cuts people apart remember at
the funeral right yeah he's the only one
that's like talking to her for her yeah
i like that about damon they're not
painting him is just like purely evil
like they're he's evil he's bad
but but there's like shades of good he
cares about his family he cares about
his lineage uh and he certainly cares
for his knees did we see viserys ever
speak uh in their language oh in the uh
in in the targaryen language no
it's just just those two they keep
talking to each other also i love when
she says drake we'll probably talk about
it later jakartas i said you're carries
dracardi drew carries drew i love what
she says
i love what she said the price is right
it comes over the mountain and then
blows fire on the dead baby uh i love
when she says it because it's
just so different than the way that
emilia clarke says it because it's
earlier in time and later well she had
to like learn it you know they're still
probably teaching it to the to the
target at this point she had she was on
her own that's true is that they're with
the horse people
like i gotta learn how to take your
dragons on my own and daenerys was like
uh genuinely like this is a really
hardcore word whereas we just saw her
have to kill like blow fire on her mom
she's also got people taking care of the
dragons for it it's very easy i also
love like you know the dragons flying
over the city in that in the beginning
the kind of opening shot and like no one
even cares they're like yeah we've seen
dragons yeah is that a big deal but when
the dragon showed up again with thrones
it was like
these are like yeah it's just a dragon
yeah cause everyone has one but game of
thrones were like i thought they were
dead
uh well before we get into more of our
our questions about this episode we want
to thank our sponsor today and that
sponsor is upside hey have you ever
noticed that the price of a burrito from
your favorite restaurant has risen more
than damon targaryen's desire to be king
and that's that's a big rise uh one
thing is clear inflation is hitting us
all where it hurts that's why at new
rockstars we've started using upside
upside is an incredible app for anyone
who buys gas groceries or dines out with
every purchase you can earn cash back
thanks to upside use that cash back to
buy the perfect souvenir on your next
road trip uh you know maybe pick
yourself up a little valerian steel from
a roadside gift shop you never know you
gotta check those antiques uh to get
started with upside all you gotta do is
download the free upside app in the app
store or google play use promo code big
question that's all one word big
question and get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more in comparison to credit
card rewards or loyalty programs you can
earn three times more cash back with
upside you can cash out at any time to
your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands upside
users are earning more than a million
dollars every week baby that's probably
why they have a 4.8 star rating in the
app store i'd use the upside app i
really like it uh what i like to do is
when the wi-fi and i it's the weekend
and it's like oh where do you want to go
to eat i go i'll think of a place and i
look at upside i see who's got a little
deal a rooney and we go there we get
dinner we get a little cash back it's a
win-win baby i'm a hero
i'm a hero [ __ ] okay thanks to upside
so all you got to do is download the
free upside app and use promo code big
question to get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that's five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more using promo code big
question all one word no spaces baby
okay you ready okay let's let's get
let's get into more of our questions
here about this episode uh i want to
talk about how uh reynos and viserys are
related to jairus
say it one more time reynolds and
varceris are related to jaehaerys uh
okay so viserys targaryen right and
reynous targaryen they're both
grandchildren of jiharis joharis was the
old man you saw at the beginning of the
episode who's like i have to pick
somebody and i have their name in a
little box
uh reimus was the daughter of a monterey
targaryen who was originally the prince
of dragonstone and heir to the throne
okay so joharis has a son uh he has one
son aegon he dies immediately uh then he
has another son amon uh who he's like
you're gonna be the heir baby uh baby
boy he grows up he has a daughter named
raynis who you saw on the show uh and
she was originally gonna be the heir to
the throne and it was all cool uh then
damon then amon died uh jaehaerys had to
choose a name he had to choose another
son to be his heir
uh right and then instead of passing it
on to uranus immediately like her father
wanted joharis chooses his fourth son
balon targaryen who's the the father of
the ceres okay
so and then baylon would die as well
before jiharis died and so that's how we
came to the problem with the great
council and everything and we don't know
how so the great council was they bring
all these lords together and they kind
of vote on who they want to be the heir
we don't know how that voting went we
don't know the numbers uh it's been
rumored that it was like heavily favored
for viserys because
uh you know it's a patriarchy and they
want to keep yeah they want like man in
charge so that the men keep power uh but
there were certainly people pulling for
reynolds and wanted her to rise to power
this is what we had they had they had
this this council the same like thing in
game of thrones with uh
at the very end right yeah when they're
all like who's gonna who's gonna rule
who's gonna do this i'm gonna do the
same thing oh my god so it's been that
long yeah i mean well this was this was
seen as a way for jaharis to kind of
keep the peace because he's like i know
i'm dying if i just pick someone there's
gonna be fighting after i die so i'm
gonna let the lords decide so that they
keep what they want that's real time and
that's how we got there
uh
so they both have a claim but certainly
reynolds i could see why the queen that
never was is pissed because it was
supposed to be her not
she's got kids of her own that she wants
to keep it in and she thinks that you
know viserys is doing a bad job and she
could do a much better job
and then honestly this is why i'm like
oh she's going to turn it up to like 40
by the second episode to watch them be
like oh i'm going to give my air my
daughter that throne next and it'd be
like remember when i wasn't given the
throne because i was a woman and now
you're giving it to this one and she's a
child i would be
wild and that's why i think she's going
to turn up she's going to be the one
that goes off well and it was funny to
see like her husband in that kind of
meeting of the king's council be like
hey you know should damon be
be the next dare because your kid died
and then and then he's kind of like well
you know we coulda had a lady and
they're like what do you want dude what
do you want make up your mind he's very
i think he wants to see a woman get to
power just to legitimize what his wife
do no i think he's just looking out for
himself and if he goes with damon and
then damon becomes the king he would be
like oh you were on my you were on my
side so you're good to go but this
mother like a high tower right here no
we gotta keep my high side
he's like i'm gonna kill him uh i think
uh valerian would stay there regardless
it's just that like if damon was king
he'd get more benefit yeah and if he's
the one who helps him become king oh
yeah i mean it's very smart if his wife
becomes king or if damon becomes or his
wife becomes queen or damon becomes king
he gets benefits and if they don't he's
just still there so it's fine
and we know these people don't really
make it to game of thrones so like
that's not really a spoiler you've seen
game of thrones there's not a lot of
valet runs walking around so
that's the hardest part about this show
is watching those people and then being
like i know what your future is i know
what you're saying and i hate you and i
hate you and i hate you
you're cool
like everyone kind of sucks
um well let's talk about some of the
weapons we saw on this show of some
renowned uh we love we love the little
like easter eggs you can find in there
um we do see king viserys walking around
with the familiar looking valerian steel
dagger you may have seen this before
right this little beauty remember this
guy uh this was the same dagger that was
used on game of thrones and the
assassination attempt on bran stark and
used to kill the night king remember him
booyah when arya killed the night king
this is that same dagger uh and i love
that it was kind of tied to the prophecy
of the song of ice and fire like this is
very important uh you know aegon the
conqueror having this like vision of
like because he lived through the doom
of valeria he saw what happened there
and he was like it's gonna happen again
over here in westeros uh we gotta be
ready you know here's the book of
secrets national treasure part two uh
keep it alive keep it safe um so it was
good to see that um and we got a clear
shot of it yeah we got a very it looks
beautiful i mean immediately you're like
oh i know that guy uh we also as we
mentioned earlier we see damon wielding
dark sister in that tournament uh
which is like a very cool again it's an
ancestral blade made of valerian steel
um we also see our boy king viserys
sitting on the throne with black fire
blackfire is like kind of the sister
blade of dark sister uh these two
uh swords they're both made of valerian
steel like i said and they were used in
the conquering of westeros by aegon the
conqueror uh and also one of his wives
vicen
yeah his dark sister aegon loved using
blackfyre uh maegor would wield both of
them at some point uh male maegor loved
using blackfyre too like any time like
someone disagreed with them he was just
like cut his head off
um but i love seeing these swords show
up was this it uh i always call her
vesnya and the
i think it's vicenza i think you're
right i think i'm no maybe you're right
she was the mean one she was the one
that was like i'm gonna i'm out just for
murder she was the she was the younger
one who like oh those nights around the
nice one they like that the older sister
wife again sister i liked her i liked
she was she was hardcore
she was so cool she was horrible she
while a visitor would go into places and
be like hi i'm very nice what's up the
other one would be like yeah
this this naya this naya i don't know
we're pronouncing call in if you know
how to say the name uh she was the one
who was like kind of more fair looking
described
yeah was lost he didn't like it she was
like all right i'll be harsh you wanna
harsh you're gonna get harder she didn't
like her it was also so rude how the
george r martin set her up in the book
it was just like yeah she wasn't good to
look at but she was tough and i was like
okay come on all right come on my guy
come on come on my guy george uh but
yeah these swords are important they're
always used in like targaryen succession
they get like stolen a lot when like
someone thinks they should be king
they're like i'm gonna take this sword
i'm gonna fly away with my dragon uh so
they're they're they're very important
uh it's good to see them we'll keep an
eye out for them uh and eric voss is
gonna have a full breakdown of this
episode up on the channel uh tomorrow
i'm sure he'll point out even more
little easter eggs but it's good to see
those swords show up let's talk about
the dornish elephant in the room okay
sir kristen cole how is this boy going
to screw everything up this beautiful
beautiful boy i think i mean he took off
his helmet and they literally almost
fainted
thank you
oh my god get them out of here uh they
won't oh wait no i can't say it
no
i think sorry um we know the dornish
right the martells if you remember the
martells uh these are these are the
people who live down in the south in the
desert and they technically don't abide
by the rules uh they never bent the knee
uh there's kind of like a piece that's
had that was established i don't know
how much we can talk about they don't
they don't like to play along okay so it
was kind of when a dornish man shows up
that no one really knew
they were kind of like oh this is kind
of what's he doing here it's also yeah
it's also like how would you get invited
how did you walk up in here you won't do
a lot of things yeah yeah yeah you guys
don't like to play along you guys sneak
in every now and then he's there to mess
things up he is there to stir a ruckus
because why would he show up other than
i guess other than to be like i'm the
best here and also i'm not gonna do
anything for you guys well it's possible
he could see that you know his people
are being left out of the seat of power
mainly because they don't want to play a
lot yeah that's the seven kingdoms right
uh and maybe he's like i need to work my
way into the kind of ranks here the
nobility ranks yeah and this is his way
to do it i think he's going to screw
things up because it's clear that both
rhaenyra and allison were like oh hello
so
i don't think he's going to be the love
interest for uh i think he's going to be
the love interest for someone and it's
going to get him killed
you think he's going to actually be in
love with someone yeah and someone's
going to be in love with him oh yeah and
he's going gonna get him
killed damon's gonna show up and be like
are you flirting with him yeah that yeah
you're my niece but are you working with
them or you know if if her and al if
alice sentence or kristen cole you know
have a little thing going on the side
because she's tired of banging the
old-ass king with pus marks all over him
uh that her dad sent her into dad of the
year otto hightower over here uh
she might you know want a little side
thing with a younger man uh of dorner's
descent and it might get him killed this
episode it might get allison killed
honestly this she's gonna die uh this
episode is father's father's father's
father's father fathers
why have a queen when the men are doing
such a great job oh my gosh
uh yeah i think he's definitely gonna
screw some things yeah for somebody i
like the idea of him actually being in
love but my thing about the dorne are in
the book i love them a lot and i don't
want him i want him to be up to no good
the fact that i want him to love him
makes me not trust him
makes him evil that is true well oh god
i can't wait till we get further in the
series i can talk about my favorite part
of the book um but yes uh i do want to
talk about a cool little thing i saw in
the episode so during the tournament as
we were saying you know princess uh
reynos valeron is talking with her
husband
um
and she kind of drops a little line you
know when like the bloodletting starts
and it starts getting brutal she kind of
like over it and she points out it's
been 70 years since maegor's end and she
says quote none have known real war but
that's also a reason why she wouldn't be
a good queen is because she's like we
need to go to war with someone and it's
like well no one wants to go to war yeah
or it's not that no one wants to it's
that just like if we don't need to why
are you making it happen i i see it as
like she sees that there's this kind of
anger boiling up with yeah 100 they need
something to release it like this is a
brutal time in in this fantasy world uh
and they need wars they need fighting
and like to her this is all just like
play fighting and she knows
uh
of what maegor did and like how awful it
was she heard about it from like her her
ancestors and like she knows that these
people are far away from that and they
don't know what a a bloodthirsty king is
like now why she would want one i don't
know but i think she sees that you need
strength on the throne or else you are
played by your counsel you're played by
the hand like you have to be strong and
be powerful or else you're going to get
played
that is true also everyone thinks they
would do a better job as king or queen
everybody does which is not correct at
all but i don't think any of them will
actually be a good king but anyways they
i think also the fact of like if war did
break out that moment none of them would
be prepared oh yeah and like the all
those bloodthirsty people in the streets
would just be like ah with their swords
and they'd be like we none of us are
prepared for this you never prepared
anyone for war uh which happens a lot in
like
the like that's the problem of like
peace time right that's when the the the
the problems and then when yeah and then
when damon comes back with an army and
you're like well
who do we have
this you guys are you guys are messed
with right you're messed with um but i
do you think her bringing up maegor's
bloody rule is like foreshadowing do you
think we're gonna i think she likes
someone bloody take the throne yeah i
want it to be which is i know horrible
me damon i mean overall like he's gonna
come forward pretty hard yeah so it's
and it's and it's just gonna be a
bloodshed and that's where the
targaryens and if people are too soft
then i could be able to stop him right
she's saying some like hard some hard
he's gonna have people on his council
and just stab them when they disagree
with him and that's what maegor would do
he would whoever disagreed with him
would just murder him but also a woman
that wants that much bloodshed like
maegor bloodshed i'm like dude you're
going to
die you're going to die trying to set
something like this up and so i don't
trust her either
and we saw this like in game of thrones
like with daenerys as she was rising to
power yeah sometimes she was
bloodthirsty and if you disagree with
that you died sometimes she'd hear you
out uh and it was like the balance of
the two oh so we're discounting the fact
that this could be how uh uh rene
mourinho's the daughter uh could be
ranera sorry god all these uh
uh
they they're so close they're literally
one letter off but um she could be that
maegor she could be like after her best
friend sleeping with her dad like she
has no one left damon's going crazy like
all this she's like like uh daenerys is
just like i'm i'm fed up with it i'm fed
up with it they're keep trying to steal
for me and i'm going to start fighting
and she's very impressionable i
we're doing the math she's about 12.
yeah she's very young when you're as
about 12 she's now been told after being
like kind of ignored by her dad and felt
like she's not loved by her dad which is
so so sad uh now he's like okay you get
to be the queen now and she's like oh
okay i mean she looked so nervous right
she did that last shot of her wasn't
like one of
full confidence it was like oh snap well
yeah go back to the scene where her and
allison are literally she's teaching her
about the history and the books and
she's just not paying attention well but
she knows
yeah doesn't care yeah yeah and she
doesn't care about that
there are like women very similar to uh
ranira in the past who were like that
were like they wanted to ride their
dragon and fly around and hang out with
other ladies and have a great time uh
and then they were kind of forced to be
involved with stuff well they were she
she seems very much like that where she
she kind of says it at the tree right
she's like i just want to fly around and
explore they can't didn't they say that
like the women that are like allison and
her were just supposed to uh be at the
hand of the council and like feed and
drink them i mean like men were allowed
yeah that's what they were like she's
the princess and she's the cupboard
is literally pouring literal drinks for
every man at this table men that are
below her yeah like it's insane it's
something they often make like the
children of the king do who aren't the
hair right yeah that's what they like
but their job is so bs and maybe that is
what they're like learn start from the
bottom like me i mean he's like i'm
being i guess that's not if of all the
things the women have to do in the land
of westeros being the cupbearer ain't so
bad
it's so bad they they treat them a lot
worse than that
um or one last thing i really want to
talk about uh
so we as we said and the the scene where
dad of the year otto hightower sends his
daughter into the king's chamber right
before that he has a little a little
scroll and he's like send a raven you
know to old town
what do you think is on on that note
that seems important that wasn't like a
throwaway well why show us that a do
they know that
the son is dead and so is the queen
you think he's alerting him so he could
be alerting them that i what i think
he's doing is i think he's up to no good
i don't think he's up tonight i think
he's like setting up like
the king's going crazy yeah king's going
crazy he's injured he's dying he's not
doing any of his jobs correctly he he's
in his room
carving the town yeah like
he needs to be stopped like i think he's
gonna get my lego set like don't talk to
me i'm doing i'm in my i'm doing my lego
don't talk to me don't talk listen i
know you want to smash yeah but i'm in
the don't bring your daughters to me
with a book to read yeah i don't want
this yeah bring a boss on my back i'm
not it yeah you're putting a book for
yourself you bring a book because i'm
not interested i'm doing my lego uh uh
it's important to remember that like old
town
was the old town it was it was the it
was the seat of power
in in the land before king's landing was
established right
uh and aegon kind of made it the capital
also in old town you have like uh the
religious folk who
as powerful as like the the king is and
the lineage and whoever sits on the iron
throne uh the religion is very powerful
too and they don't like the targaryens
because the targaryens like incest and
they're very much against oh yeah they
yeah and so they it's a very tenuous
relationship because the the targaryens
know you kind of have to keep the
priests happy because they they have a
lot of uh you know in every little town
there's a there's a church
and they they can spread whatever
message they want very quickly and they
can turn the people against uh the
monarchy when they want to yeah um so
you have to kind of keep them at uh very
close i think otto is reaching out being
like look there's some shady dealings
going on but i'm trying to get my
daughter in there who is not targaryen
blood is a little fresh blood oh okay
i'm i'm trying to secure this so you
guys need to support what i'm doing here
100 okay okay so maybe oh that but then
that makes it's like do you think the
church will literally be like yeah we're
not gonna talk about it i think the
church would love to get targaryens out
of power
because they're tired of these dragon
writing mf ers telling them what to do
okay let's get them out of there true so
i think they they're for any plan that's
like that also we got to remember uh
otto hightower the high towers they're
an old town they have a lot of power
there and remember they pointed out that
otto he's like the second son he has
nothing he doesn't get to inherit a lot
of like the hightower
uh fortune or whatever that's why he's
like the hand of the king he's power
hungry he wants to rise up uh and i
think i think he's trying to turn the
church
and whatever power he has in old town
against
or
any other plan than his daughter
becoming one
becoming the new queen and then whatever
heir they have getting the lineage i
think he's trying to take over there god
damn there's so much sneaky so much
shady things so much sneaky shitty
things um well before we get out of here
today we want to discuss uh we'll do
this every episode little power rankings
uh who's moving up who's moving down uh
so let's talk about it who do you think
moved up the most in power in this
episode who who would be your pick who
gains the most power in this first
episode
you want me to be crazy be crazy i think
it's damon you think damon gained the
most power because you sent him away
with a dragon to a place where he can
just create his anything he can rule
they do his eyes on him so yeah
you no one's keeping eyes on him i mean
there will be a maester there yeah who's
busy killing people
just murder just digging his hands into
every woman but no i think i just think
that was too
you had eyes on him you gave him the
golden cloaks that was it you and you
guys kept him away from the council by
putting him with the cloaks so you have
now this pack of wolves doesn't have
their lead wolf yes oh my god so it's
just like he's just gonna create more
chaos somewhere else and then show up in
like a year
i just think it's more it's it it gave
him like two steps forward instead of
two suspects by doing it i mean i'm i'm
gonna go with the safe bet here i think
uh rhaenyra targaryen gained the most oh
well yeah she gained a lot of power i
mean she doesn't have it yet but she's
gained a lot she's been pushed up she
had all the lords like take the knee to
her you know what i mean that's a lot of
power uh it's dangerous for her that's a
lot of power uh my honorable mention
would also be alison i think she gained
a little if i don't think she could if
they banged if they hooked up she did a
little paper if she did but if they did
if she just watched him do some lego you
know maybe maybe not so much she's just
a massage i think ramirez certainly
gained the mice most okay now let's talk
about who lost the most who's down on
power right now
i'm gonna say damon is down on power i
think he's there obviously he's down bad
my boy's been down bad he lost the
tournament to some dornish boy no one
ever heard of okay
get out of here it doesn't matter
compared to what he did yeah but the
people the people saw that the people in
that vaginal shape stadium saw what
happened but you know who didn't see it
the ones that he attacked in the street
that night before so that's what i'm
like it kind of cancels each other out
it's like yeah you guys saw him get beat
but also don't walk up on him in the
like the alley he's gonna say thief
do you think the guy got his hand cut
off do you think he invented foam
fingers for i think he absolutely did a
tournament they were like and they said
get that out of here take his other hand
get that out of here that's right i
think i think damon's down in power
because like
he loses a tournament you know he gets
kicked out of uh king's landing uh his
brother's pissed at him i think his
brother being mad at him it's better
when his brother likes him uh his
brother being mad at him is bad and he's
kicked out of town he's got to go back
to his he claims homely wife uh we don't
know what she looks like but uh he says
she's what dragon what dragon does the
series have he does what dragon does the
series happens actively is like that's
the thing viserys does not a dragon he's
not like a dragon rider yeah he takes
this badass dragon with him he's got
dark sister he takes his
mistress with him we'll see how the wife
feels about that
she gets to go along for the ride i
think he's down on power
who do you think is who who lost the
most power in this episode
uh
honestly certainly not damien you don't
think no i don't think it's i think you
gave him just a full playground uh a
full playground of imagination to soar
okay sore literally no pun intended um
honestly it's it's real it's a tie for
me between allison and between um
valerian
because he kept he keeps trying to get
higher on the council and he keeps
getting knocked down and then the the uh
husband yeah reyna and reyna's deserves
i i stand by her yeah she def and then
having to watch all that happen yeah i
am going to excuse every angry behavior
she has in the series and but i'm still
like girl you're you're not going
anywhere now you're just going back
because now she's gonna show up yeah
she's coming forward you're just gonna
keep and as you get older you're just
going back and now we got a young a 12
year old about to take the throw that's
not you but allison only because i'm
like once she does hook up with the king
it's downhill from there
because the king's gonna die and then
there's gonna be left with yeah uh it's
gonna be left with uh uh renee rin
reenies rainey's
i'm going to start calling them by the
actor's actual name
uh it's going to be left with her and
she's going to kick him to the curb we
were all like this episode one of game
of thrones we were all like whose name i
don't know nicknames so it was easier
and they didn't sound exactly the same
yeah because they weren't all cousins
having sex with each other
i wish they were just cousins it's a lot
of brother sister stuff a lot of mothers
uncles
i also think viserys targaryen lost a
lot of power in this episode because
he's dying he's still the king but like
yeah he's basically just like he's a
lame duck now
what's your name an heir like you're
done my guy that is true like you're
you're getting caught on the throne you
got pus everywhere
your wife's dead your male hair he's
dead goddamn don't kick him while he's
down
boy's down bad boy's down bad uh you
know he's just that your council's
telling you what to do
you know everyone's bringing their
marbles and they're like get out of here
dude we don't even need you anymore
you're done
so yeah that's that's my second pick for
who who's down in power uh in this
episode
uh but i think
that about sums up the first episode of
the house of the dragon i think it was
great i'm so excited to be back in
westeros it felt nice uh like slipping
into a warm bath
attempted bath
blood blood and gas blood and castration
you know keep the water at a nice level
that the maesters say is okay for me and
my baby
what was that flower the give me all
that milk of the poppy give me all that
milk you better shoot that straight into
my veins my guy this is a painful birth
better give me that milk of the poppy uh
but that's it for this episode of big
question presents talking dragons uh be
sure to be sure to join us here each and
every week uh on new rockstars we'll be
spitting fire with all these targaryens
and talking about all the episodes uh we
also will there's going to be some more
fantasy shows coming out very soon rings
of power comes out uh we'll be talking
about that on this show as well so much
fantasy to cover the witcher uh the
witcher's coming back maybe in two years
maybe maybe we'll cover the witcher i
don't know i got the hair but we want to
hear your thoughts on all these series
uh be sure to drop your theories and
questions uh in the comments like we
said eric voss will have a full
breakdown of this episode up on the
channel tomorrow so be sure to check
that out and don't forget to check out
our many great merch options at new
rockstars merch uh
follow jessica at luluclemons on twitter
follow me at grinnenberric and be sure
to subscribe to bigquestion wherever you
get your podcast thanks so much for
watching this episode we will be with
you right here next week until then
bye-bye
[Music]
you